tyler1 could still demonstrate that he's
stronger than any super Grand Master on
Earth physically with big arms and a
bigger brain Tyler also proved to be the
stronger contender in his match against
Ginny with tyler1 missing mating ideas
over and over he eventually found a
Checkmate to secure the win that was a
good one the second game was even more
wild where somehow tyler1 promoted his
d-pawn on A8 oh no Eddie's got a quit on
the board he's a magician at this point
Ginny's pieces started to disappear from
the board until tyler1 used his two
Queens on the board to Checkmate in a
final position where he was up 30 points
of material this gave him the Swagger to
challenge Levy Rosman Hikaru Nakamura
and Magnus Carlson after the game you
could put me against that hikiro guy or
the Magnus Carlsen guy with 199 rating